which neil stephenson book should one
read first
so when people ask me that i usually ask
them what they like to read right
because uh i mean
there's
the best known one is probably snow
crash but that's a
a cyberpunk novel that's at the same
time making fun of cyberpunk um so
it's kind of got some layers to it that
uh might not
seem so funny if you don't have that if
you don't get the joke right
so um
there's uh i've written as you point out
i've written historical novels some
people like those some people prefer
those so if that's what you like
then cryptonomicon or the baroque cycle
is where you would start if you like
sort of techno thrillers that are set in
a
modern day setting but aren't science
fictiony per se
then uh reem d um
is one of those and termination shock
is is definitely one of those
um
so it just depends on
on uh what people like
what what uh when people a long time ago
recommend i read snow crash they said uh
it's the
it's neil stevenson light
it's it's the uh
like if you don't want to be overwhelmed
by the depth like the rigor
a book like that's a good that's a good
introduction
okay so so essentially you broke it down
by topics but
if you wanted to read all of them
what's a good introduction to the to the
man because obviously these worlds are
very different yeah the philosophies are
very different
yeah what's a good introduction to the
human
um
people ask the same thing with
dostoyevsky people right
it's a hard one to answer
maybe seven eaves
because it's got big themes
it's you know it's about heavy
heavy things happening to the human race
um
uh but hopefully the story is told
through a cast of characters that
people can relate to
you know it moves along
so uh it it does go kind of deep
eventually on
how rockets work and orbital mechanics
and all that stuff but
um
people were able to get through it
anyway or some people just skip over
that
it's fine
you know
you